hey everybody its Jesse and I haven't
haven't streamed in a while had a
holiday yesterday fourth of July here in
the US and the day before that my boss
got married so I took the day off and
went to his wedding so it's been since
last week we we did some really some
like design work on it was a Friday we
had at the last dream and actually let
me show you let me show you what I kind
of settled on for the moment just to let
you know how it went so if you remember
we were going with like a really short
section and at the very end of the
stream it was a long stream so I don't
know how many people stuck around for
the end but at the very end someone
mentioned that it looks like an
old-school WordPress header and then I
made up my mind that I had to change it
because I couldn't have that so I left
it a little bit bigger than normal and
kept a lot of the same I kept it
basically same as it originally was
shrunk it a little bit adjusted line
Heights and made this a bit bigger made
the font a bit bigger increase the font
weight so all the changes are are much
more minor than what we had originally
done on Friday so this is what I'm going
with for now of course I'll have to see
what everyone else that's involved in
the project thinks about that but that's
it for now the only other changes I made
since Friday are I took out this there
was a contact form section here I took
that out I got an email this morning
saying that they didn't want that in
there and there's some other sections
and they're gonna be taken out and
rearranged here but other than that the
home page is pretty much finished I
think I think I'm going to get different
images for these sections and that's
I'll just see whatever images I'm giving
for that and hopefully they all can can
work with these dimensions but today
we're gonna work on the resource section
specifically we're gonna work on sorting
so we might do a little bit of UI work
here because we're gonna need to add
some toggles and a drop-down maybe but
the most important thing is getting the
sorting to work so that users can pick a
category they can toggle whether they
want the free or the paid resources you
know this obviously already works and
then they could even search within that
so they can just really narrow down on
what they exactly what they want
so I'm streaming from home again so if
you've joined in before when I've
streamed from home the quality isn't
always great but I had to work from home
again today so let me know if if
anything is is really really off the
setting I left the same settings as out
on Friday and it seemed ok on Friday the
video quality is not HD which that kind
of stinks I would rather it be HD but at
least the the buffering wasn't too bad
on Friday but let me know if it gets bad
there's not really that much I can do
about it but maybe I can change some
settings here I'm gonna go to the live
chat as quickly and say hello before we
get started sorry I had I don't have
anything set up as much as I normally do
I just concluded a an interview a phone
interview with with a candidate so that
ended just a few minutes before the
stream hey everyone oh hey hey bill bill
hasn't been able catch a stream in a
while so I'm glad you could watch this
one
hey Fabian how's it going yeah I haven't
seen you in the stream for a while it's
good to see you yeah
the github sue rev asks about the
github link so the link for the github
repo for this project is in the
description there's not exactly a
tutorial to follow but if you check the
videos I actually started this website I
think on my own channel so I think
there's like two streams that are on my
youtube channel and that's linked in the
description and then I got invited to
stream for free code camp so I've
switched everything over to them so it's
a lot of content some of the streams are
pretty long but if you went through them
it would be somewhat of a tutorial but
not not comprehensive at all the goal of
this show in case you're joining for the
first time is just to to work watch me
work with me
as I do my normal everyday thing so
there's a lot of things that I work on
for this project that I don't record so
that's why you won't get exactly you
know comprehensive tutorial but I try to
title all the videos accurately in terms
of what I'm doing so you know there are
some aspects of what we're doing that
are tutorial like and you you probably
get a good idea of how to do it but no
not really any official tutorials yet
yeah it is someone asked about the
resolution it's 480p right now that's
basically my upload right now is below 5
megabits per second so I can't
consistently stream at a high enough
bitrate to get 720p so I dropped it down
to 480 because if I try to do 720 I
can't sustain it and there's lots of
buffering or ATP seems to be the max I
can get on my home network so yeah I
know a couple people are saying they
don't like the 4 TPI I watched the
recording the last video and I really
couldn't stand the 480 but I figure I
guess it's better to just you know do a
stream than to not do one because I
don't know when I'm gonna be able to get
back into
into the office so I might be doing a
bunch of streams from home huh I don't
want to be away from you all for that
long of a period of time I don't know
about you but I like have gotten used to
interacting with you all you know four
sometimes five times a week and I start
to miss you when when I don't stream for
a while so I thought it would be good to
just do the the stream and all right so
we have it looks like yeah we have a
really good amount of viewers today
actually more than normal so we're up to
you know over 90 viewers so that's great
so I don't want to leave everyone
hanging with introductions let's get to
it just to explain in case you haven't
seen what we're doing here we're pulling
in these are resources this sections
gonna undergo a big kind of design
update here not on this video but it
will soon probably sometime this week so
what we're gonna do or what we are doing
is we're pulling in data JSON data from
WordPress via the WordPress API so all
these resources are added in by someone
else who handles the content into the
WordPress back-end we pull it in here to
this site which is a react site so
that's what we're going to be sorting
through we're gonna get in JSON data and
then we're gonna be adding in filters
and we're gonna include some sorting I
don't have anything in the UI right now
that really like would would sort things
so we're gonna have to add some elements
in for that as well but we want to be
able to filter that data by categories
so there'll be a drop-down with a bunch
of categories we want to be able to
filter whether it's free a free resource
or paid resource and there'll be a
toggle for that the search is already
working these already work but we may
change exactly how these interacts so
we'll see once we get into it whether we
need to change
so that's the plan and I'm not gonna
worry as much about the UI yet in the
design yet because I think that the
sorting and filtering is the most
important part and if I get that down
and you get it working you know then I
can fine-tune the design aspects of it
later on so right now I was working I
think I'm gonna switch to another branch
so if you're following along on github
let me pull this over just really
quickly and show you what we're working
on
what branch were working on I'll make
this bigger I'm have to make everything
extra big I think - just to make up for
the low res video so everything that we
did on Friday and that I've done since
then is on the home alt branch so if
you're checking on github that's the you
need to switch to that branch to see it
for these resources actually I think I'm
gonna make a new branch for this and if
you're not familiar with git or github a
branch is just like an alternate version
of your your project and you can switch
to that branch make any changes you want
and then switch back to the original
branch and everything's still in the
same condition you left it so it's nice
to be able to make you add new features
and if you need to switch back to the
main branch and make a quick fix on
something that came up you can do that
and then you'll push that up to
production that can be live and then you
can just switch right back to your
feature branch and work on that until
it's ready to go so it's super useful
I've gone in some previous videos in
more depth into and to get but I haven't
done a tutorial yet I hope to do so soon
but there are a lot of great get
tutorials out there even on this channel
in free code camp there's a whole
playlist about using get in and github
so if you want to learn more about it I
recommend checking that out so let's I
I'm just going to check
just to make sure I don't have anything
okay so this branch is clean I'm just
gonna push it up to github just so that
I have it in case I need to work from a
different computer and so that you all
can see all the changes as well and
let's change I think I'm going to name
this branch resource sorting I guess
that works so we're gonna git git branch
it's is this easy if you haven't done
this before and get github or with git I
mean it's it's super easy just get
branch and then type the name of the
branch that you want to create and
actually I'm gonna let me go I'm gonna
go back to the master branch first I'm
not really sure I'm sure you know you
all probably know this but I didn't want
to get a copy of the home old branch and
start from that I wanted to start from
master so I didn't know if that would
make a difference just the web branch I
was in but just in case I do want to
make a copy of the master branch to
start with this so I don't know we're
gonna be doing more than sorting but
this will be a decent name out at least
I'll be able to remember it so now if we
go get branch it'll list all our
branches so we have resource sorting so
now we can go to that so we get checkout
and there are shortcuts for like pretty
much every command you want to do and
get so you don't always have to type all
this out there we go now we're on our
own branch so now I can do anything on
this branch and it won't mess up
anything else you're doing on any other
branches all right so let's go over to
our code and we'll go into resources let
me make this a bit bigger okay let me
know if it needs to be bigger than that
I'll show you what's going on just in
case you haven't seen any of the videos
where we worked on this I mean we're in
porting just some basic layout
components our resources are all in
cards and that's a separate component
but this is this is gonna undergo a
major change so we're ly gonna leave it
for now but that will definitely change
we're importing we've we've extracted
and not me actually I think you did it I
think it was Patrick who submitted a
pull request that took that all of our
our fetch our functions that we're using
to fetch data and put it into its own
component so that's out of here it
cleans things up a little bit and we
don't have to include the same things in
every every page so that's nice and then
we had gotten masonry working before
this is kind of sad for me because if
you remember that was a really kind of a
long stream when we tried to get masonry
working and now I don't even think I'm
gonna need it for the page so sad about
that but I will definitely be using it
in future sites so it will not be a
waste of of effort alright so basically
all we're doing is you know we've we've
set up our state we have a place for our
data to live here in our state and we
get our initial request here and this is
we're using next js' to kind of scaffold
out or react up and in XJS if you want
to render on the cert if you want to
make the API call on a server side to be
able to render that into the HTML and
then send it to the client on that first
load you have to do it inside get
initial props and of course that saves
it the prop so we have to transfer that
then to the state so that's all we're
doing here so this thing here is just
fetching the data and it does it
isomorphic lis so this would actually
take care of fetching it on the
server-side and then if they were if you
went there we're using client-side
routing so if they navigated to this
page using the client-side routing then
it would also work as well so we're just
transferring that from props to state
and we want to transfer that to state
because we want reacts to be able to
rerender every time the state changes
and that's going to be key for our
sorting because every time we sort or
filter anything all we're gonna do is
change how these things are set up in
state and then react is automatically
gonna know and I know most of you know
this already but just in case there's
some people that aren't familiar with
react I'm kind of going through it react
is gonna know about the change and it's
gonna rerender everything okay so that's
great if you've done anything like with
trying to setup maybe like a single page
app with jQuery or something you know
it's crazy to have all these event
listeners and everything so we don't
even worry about that everything is nice
and contained in State react takes care
of so much of that so here's where we
actually get to some of the stuff you
know we're already doing some actually
saw in this page I was thinking we were
doing some filtering on this page but it
it was on the events page so that's
where you viewed on it so we may
actually just copy some code from the
events page as well and I'll bring that
up right now cuz we're definitely gonna
want to copy some stuff from that page
so here's what we're doing so we bring
in our data and we can set filters on
the data right away and that's key you
want to filter before you do sorting or
mapping or anything because then you'll
have a smaller set of data for
everything to have to be put through
after that so in this case we right away
just filter out any events that have
already happened that had a date
previous to today's date and then after
that we can
we mapped the events into you know
basically acts components hey and I'm
not doing any sorting here oh yeah I am
I didn't remember this because somebody
else actually did this as well I think
it was Patrick as well if I'm giving
credit to the wrong person let me know
but I thought it was Patrick that
submitted this pull request where is
actually using a sort for our sorting by
distance okay so that's our basic things
that we're going to use here mainly
filter and sort and then when we're all
filtered and sorted out sorted how we
want it then we use map to just iterate
over all those things and put them into
you know the components that we need to
get them rendered on the page and then
everything is going to be set into state
to trigger the rerender all right so I'm
gonna go back to if I lost you in a live
chatter you have any questions throw
them in there right now I'll check it
very quickly before we start actually
coding stuff I just don't want to lose
anybody you know this early on
okay great it looks like okay it looks
like the video is decent some people are
saying they can read it it's decent
quality um Ahmed says it it's kind of
cute that I said I don't want to be away
from you officer I know it's true I've
been pleasantly surprised at the
community that's kind of been built up
around this I really feel like I always
did my work alone I was a freelancer I
basically worked alone from my house and
now where I work I'm basically alone in
what I do there's one other guy that
does some web related like web
development stuff but we always work on
different projects so I'm just kind of
alone in my office most of the time I
mean there are days when I come in early
I don't see anybody and I don't see
anybody all day
I'll come out of the office to go home
later on and my co-workers will say oh I
didn't even know you're here how so
it's really really cool and unique for
me to have this whole community of
people and we're all like working
together you know on these projects so
it's been amazing I I didn't think
anybody would even be interested in this
when I started doing it so this has all
been a very wonderful surprise for me so
anyway enough of the sappy stuff I just
I do appreciate you all so thank you
hello a lot of people saying hello hey
everyone
okay bill says I like to use get check
out - be this with the flag bee and then
branch name to create a new branch and
immediately check it out so I don't
accidentally start working on my master
branch that's a great idea so I'm just
gonna throw this this command up just so
that everyone can see it even if you
can't see the live chat now or if you're
watching later on I'm gonna throw this
command up here so bill saying if you do
check out so beta it would be get check
out which I didn't I didn't copy the
guid part so if you type git checkout
and then you have this flag be and then
type your branch name you'll
automatically move to that branch and
that bill says you don't accidentally
start working on master branch so
awesome I'm gonna try to remember that
for myself as well cuz I can see that
being really really useful so thank you
for that okay
someone says they wanted just a little
bit bigger so let's go up I'll go up a
little bit more I think if I go too big
I think it's just gonna be hard to see
enough of the code to really know what's
going on so if you really need it to be
bigger let me know I can try to go
bigger but I think we're getting to the
point now where it's kind of at our
limit of what's reasonable
nantan has a question how come you're
using WordPress as a database instead a
MongoDB bill bill has
a good answer to that and I'll just give
a just a brief answer in case you can't
see the live chat WordPress is very easy
for people who don't know how to code to
edit things in WordPress so WordPress is
my content management system because
there's going to be different people a
lot of like student workers that are
gonna be entering data and they're gonna
have varying levels of experience with
just websites in general at all so I
needed it to be as user friendly as
possible as simple as possible and I
know that WordPress is very simple to to
use so that's why I went with WordPress
I I would like at some point to be able
to find an alternative that's just as
easy to use that I could use instead of
WordPress because WordPress can be
resource heavy at times I'd love to be
able to find something that's written in
with with node instead of PHP and then I
just wouldn't have to worry about PHP at
all but until that time WordPress is my
go-to for content management systems if
I need it
even just to pull data into a react site
or an app or something I still think
it's one of the most user-friendly
options available and it's stable
there's a huge community there's
constantly security releases coming out
so I can be confident that it's gonna
work you know and it's it's gonna be
pretty reliable so that's why I've been
using WordPress Bill asks about Keystone
j/s if anyone's used it I actually I've
tried Keystone but I tried it I tried a
bunch of new CMS's all at the same time
so I can't even remember exactly what
was unique about Keystone but I'll have
to try it out again ok so it seems as if
the code is okay to read but the folders
are small yeah
there's no at least to my knowledge I'm
using Adam as my editor there's no easy
shortcut way for me to make this text
bigger I can make this text bigger just
with a simple like command plus but it
doesn't work when I try to do it over
here so for now
the folders are as they are if if
there's something over here that I
really think you should see maybe I can
try to zoom in or I'll just read it out
but for now the folders will be pretty
hard to read okay so it looks like I've
gotten through any questions than
anybody had okay one more question is
popped up so Andrea asks are you
blocking your WordPress front end from
visitors somehow and the answer is not
yet
so I think I mentioned a long time ago
that the intention I had was to block
people from going to the WordPress site
which I normally do when I have a setup
like this but I've been so busy with
other things with the site I haven't
done it yet
part of the reason is I don't think it's
on a subdomain and most people won't go
to it the only thing I would be worried
about potentially is I don't want that
to get indexed by search engines ever
there's no links to it anywhere so the
odds of that happening you're probably
low but still I am going to block it and
basically the the easiest way that I've
found to block it is to just go into
your templates your wordpress templates
and just take everything out because
that's what renders everything it would
be like you know going into react and
just taking this index you know it's is
basically as simple as find the
equivalent of index J s for WordPress
which would it be a PHP file and just
pull everything out just like literally
delete everything from that file save it
and then when a user tries to go that
site they'll see a blank screen I have
done in the past on test sites instead
of removing everything and leaving it
I've removed everything and then added a
full screen YouTube embed of the Rick
Astley song so I rickroll everybody that
tries to get to my site but I can't do
that on official University websites so
but if you ever find one of my test
WordPress installations then you may see
that yeah someone asked about the
quality again I'm really sorry about the
quality I wish I have the best internet
I can possibly buy right now my at my
house and it's it's still not great so I
hope I can get better one day but it's
just I'm limited to this right now so
let's get to let's just pick what we
want to do at first I think the easiest
thing to do right now will probably be
the toggle for whether the resources
free or paid that way we don't have to
come up with any like pretend category
names or anything like that we'll just I
already have data in the JSON file that
tells me whether it's free or paid but
I'm currently not pulling in the names
of categories so to save us from having
to go in and and make all this you know
fake data just to get this to work we'll
go with the toggle at first so I'm gonna
pull up we have been using materialized
so we're using material design and we're
kind of basing everything off of that
but in particular we're using the
materialized framework to trying to help
get a jumpstart on all of our UI stuff
so we're gonna grab the the code for a
toggle let's see there we go
switches I guess they're calling them
switches here I was wrong on the toggle
so basically I want something like this
but instead of on/off it's gonna say
free and paid obviously will have a
different color as well but that's
basically it this is what we need so
really simple we'll just copy that
and we'll put that into our page let's
see this is where I want to find where
we have the search bar because I want it
right to the left of the search bar well
that's so this is higher up in the page
[Music]
this is the middle section here we go
this file this react component is
getting a lot bigger than I normally
like components to be so it may need to
to be cut down and broken up a bit and
other components but for now we'll work
with it as is all right so here's our
tabs so above that is our search input
and right now we can just use the
regular column classes to align this so
this input field is taking up half of
the screen and we're offsetting it by
half so on a medium screen it takes up
six out of twelve columns and we've
offset it by six columns and that's how
we got it to be aligned to the right
instead of you know normally it would be
aligned left by default
so we're gonna want to align now
actually there's a plug-in now the where
I don't even have to type class names so
this will work but normally without that
that plug-in you have to type in class
name instead of class if you're you're
using JSX
so I'm gonna do class call alone and
we're going to do I think we can get
away with an s2 is this is gonna be a
small input or I'm sorry and I'm not
gonna worry about the small screens yet
it probably doesn't warrant having it's
an entire row on its own but maybe but
for now we'll just have have the whole
full width on small
on medium screens we're gonna make it
too and then we want to offset this by
four that's all we really have left
right so we had six this is gonna take
up two so we only have four left so
we're gonna offset that before so and
this is this column system is all from
the materialised framework so we're just
following that I haven't customized it
in any way so within that is where we
can put our our switch now the nice
thing about having the the plugin and
once again this was something that I
didn't do myself someone else did on a
pull request and now I'm starting I've
had so many of you help on this I'm
starting to forget who did what so I
apologize that I can't remember for sure
who added the I'll show you what it is
here and our package.json it's this
react HTML attribute attrs so this lets
you just write normal HTML without
having to worry about using like class
name instead of class and HTML for
instead of just 4 so that's really
useful if you have to copy and paste
chunks of HTML otherwise if you've been
using reactor probably used to just type
in class or class name anyway so it's
probably not a big deal but it
definitely helps for copy and pasting so
we're gonna change our labels free and
then pay and that should be all it
should be it like that it'll give us
what we want so let's check it out I'll
move this off the screen because we
won't need this anymore and if you
wanted to learn more I have up the mdn
documentation for sort which we're going
to end up using I don't know how
we'll get to it today I don't want the
video to be really really long but we'll
say but in any case if you're interested
especially if we don't get to it check
out this I mean you just find it an NBN
just search for sort and there's a lot
of good info I mean it's really it's
kind of I like this page occasionally
the mdn pages will be just like it's too
much for me like I just can't I can't
figure out I have to read it several
times but this in particular seemed to
be pretty straightforward and easy to
understand oh we didn't close our input
side all right I love when we get errors
live because then it's like a good a
good learning moment so in the input tag
we have to close it I'm sure someone
said it already in the live chat that
always you always catch my mistakes
before I do so everything has to be
closed out in JSX which is like the
react version of HTML so let's close it
out and it should work there we go all
right so check it out we have this
little switch here it works so obviously
I wouldn't leave it up here like that
and I would change the color but for now
I'm not worried about that I just wanted
to switch so based on what the switches
we're gonna do some filtering I'm gonna
check the live chat quickly just to make
sure I don't get too far behind I've I
found it's usually been my custom in the
past to wait till the end to answer
questions in the live chat but we've
been having so much activity in the live
chat that it actually starts to just cut
off all the stuff from the beginning so
I have to kind of go back now
periodically or else I will I will miss
your questions and I have no way to get
them back so that's why I'm kind of
trying to check it more often than
normal now
okay in regard to Keystone J's which is
an alternative content management system
to WordPress Bill said it appealed to
him because it was with node and [ __ ]
that's okay now I remember that one
that's why it appealed to me as well I'm
definitely gonna check out Keystone
obviously I'm not gonna use it for this
project cuz it's already so far advanced
but I have some some smaller project and
some really big projects that are gonna
happen within the next year or two and
you know if I can find an alternative to
WordPress that's suitable I'm definitely
interested in using it well bill says
Rick roll the Rick Rolled front end is
is hilarious
yeah it was pretty funny I mean I I
don't even know if anybody ever saw it
but it was funny for me Oh
Rohan says I could use the robots.txt
file to block that's that's actually a
good idea I can't believe I hadn't
thought of it I'm also gonna probably
pull out everything in the the PHP
template files as well just just to be
safe but that's also a good idea okay
looks like there's some discussion and a
lot chat about Keystone Jas so just for
time I'm gonna skip over the discussion
but it seems really promising to check
it out if you're interested
oh cool Patrick has included a link to
be able to set up change the text size
for the UI or in particular you know the
things over here that you all had
mentioned that it's really hard to read
you know these file names so awesome
Thank You Patrick I'm gonna copy this
now so it doesn't get lost in the chat
and I'll check that out so I'm gonna add
this just to my page of random stuff
here there we go so
good looks McGee says taxation is theft
all right not sure what that has to do I
don't think I said anything relating to
that but yeah I don't like taxes either
so I mean I guess we need them but I'd
rather not have to pay them right uh-huh
also one black ded says D stream
regularly I do stream regularly my
schedule has been a little weird to last
like two weeks because I was on vacation
and then it was a holiday and I took
it's today's off so normally I stream at
2 p.m. Eastern time Monday through
Friday although the time sometimes I
have to change depending on what's going
on and then occasionally I just have to
cancel completely for a day but that's
my normal time ok now let's go back and
now that we have our UI element in there
we can grab this this value checks we
don't even need to value first we can
test it out just kind of manually and
then hook up this this check box and
that's all it is it this is just a check
box it's a normal check box you get the
value like you would normally do for a
check box it just looks it doesn't look
like a regular check box actually I
forgot to check I don't know if anyone's
familiar with the materialized framework
I assume that this is not using any
JavaScript to accomplish the styling for
this check box switch here if it is
though that's going to be a problem when
we go to do the the server-side I don't
think it I didn't have to initialize
this at all so I'm hoping it doesn't use
JavaScript and it's just plain CSS I
suppose we'll find out at some point if
that's the case we'll have to redo that
because I want to do it you know write
it within
react component and not rely on jQuery
which is what is used for most of the
materialized JavaScript alright so let's
go up here and figure out where we're
gonna do this sorting so
I guess it doesn't matter we'll just put
it put it here in another function I
want to put it above the just for
organization purposes I want to put it
sorry it's not a hard question I just I
guess so I'll just put it here at the
bottom right above the render function I
guess that'll be that'll be fine all
right so we'll go free the price price
toggle that works that ik that explains
what what this does I'm gonna make this
I'm gonna use an arrow function for this
and then that way this in terms of like
the JavaScript this will be bound
correctly just in case I need it so if
you're not familiar with arrow functions
I've explained it a couple times already
so I'm gonna skip over it for those of
you that already heard my explanation of
several times but if you can either
check out a previous video or there's so
much information about arrow functions
online and why they're good especially
in particular with to use within react
actually I think the react documentation
itself explains this alright so within
this we want to get let's see what I
called okay so we're just we just call
it data within state so we want to do
this dot said state okay so I'm going to
set the state and as as some of you in
the live stream informed me maybe a few
weeks ago it made shorten for me we
never want to directly modify state
we always want to use this set state
function otherwise reactant won't know
about the change and you won't get that
rerender that you that you want so we
want to change it within here
okay so we're using this set state and
we want to take data so we want to
change what data is and then within
there what we want to do I might have to
bring up the the actual JSON data
because I don't remember what I called
the field but basically what we want to
do is filter so we want to take this
state dot data and then we're gonna
filter and I am actually gonna have to
look this up now because I will need to
know what what we're getting and I could
probably to speed this up by copying if
you remember I said I'd already done
some filtering format in events so I
probably could have just copied yeah I
mean I don't need it to be this do this
much but basically basically that's all
we need
yeah there's not even any point coffee
nut but I do need to get the data so let
me grab if you see up here where we're
initially getting the data I'm just
gonna get this because this will give us
most likely the contents of what data is
gonna be so I'll go over here and we'll
go to WP
and we want VJ song I know that that's
probably really small here but I'll
increase the size on the actual JSON
data
alright see this is how it comes mr.
data so here we go
price well that that makes sense at
least I named it something reasonable I
couldn't remember it but it makes sense
so I think the options are either free
or paid so looks like I don't see
anything paid right now but I'm pretty
sure the options are free or paid so we
just needed what data a CF price okay so
what we want to do within our filter you
want a filter only if we're gonna have
to do a bit more to this but for now
this will just give us the first step
here so did
actually I don't need sorry okay that's
it I was wondering what I'm just calling
it post sorry just checking it trying to
look back at what I did earlier so I
guess
you
okay actually I didn't get a live chat
for a second because uh Fabian has a
good point here and Fabian has helped a
lot in making this project much better
than it would have been if they would
you spend me working on it so when he
says something I
I always pay attention so his advice is
I wouldn't change data state but use the
render function to display a filtered
view of data instead by saving price
filter parameter in States okay
all right I'm a thing that weigh in on
in a live chat if anyone else has an
opinion on that because that seems like
a good idea to me but if if we're gonna
talk about changing I'm gonna do this
then I might as well open it up to
discussion so if anyone has any opinions
so basically we're talking about is
instead of changing data and having two
rerender happen like that why not have a
different like within the render
function have a totally different view
that gets toggled on and off based on
the value of the price filter which
would also be saved in state okay cool
so everybody likes that also I will say
this just in case this wasn't clear from
before so that I'm safe for farther
ahead here it is so the the user
experience that I want to happen is that
someone would then once they picked free
or paid would then be able within that
either with that free or paid be able to
pick a category and the category would
still show basically everything would be
filtered let's say to paid then filtered
further by category and then be able to
be filtered further by these tabs
and then even further by the search so
if that changes anything let me know but
that's the the functionality I want each
filter to kind of stack on the other
ones so it's not gonna take away
whatever there you know it's not like
it's gonna start from a blank slate of
like all the data again all those
filters are going to add up kind of like
how Amazon does where you can you know
check at least on the mobile app like
you can check off they have a drop-down
on the side and I you know you could say
I want everything to be like prime
eligible and I only want to see things
that are four stars and up and I want
those like both to be in effect both of
those filters at the same time so okay
good so patrick says that's even more
reason to save filters and state and
display based on them awesome great so
that's good so now it's a great time to
give my my usual disclaimer for this
show I don't claim to be an expert in
anything that I'm doing I am employed as
a full-time front-end developer at a
university this show is not me saying I
know everything listen to me this show
is me just saying hey this is my normal
workflow and I'm open to any suggestions
that you have I learned a lot on the
show and from you all and hopefully you
you know some of you at least learned
something for me or at least from the
other people in the live chat so I just
always feel the need to give that
disclaimer at certain times especially
like this whenever we're kind of
changing the I'm changing the plan on
the fly here based on your feedback so I
don't want to mislead anybody to think
that you know they should that I somehow
I'm saying that I know all this because
I don't I'm still learning this all
right so what we need to do then is have
you probably initialize in state what we
want and we'll have default so this is
going to be price
the default the default should probably
be paid it depends like from a user
standpoint they probably want to see the
free stuff but from a business
standpoint it probably makes more sense
to have the paid stuff show up first
so don't don't hate me for that but I
just think that that makes more sense so
we want the default to be paid right
bill says I need a graphic to throw up
on the screen with your disclaimer yeah
that's true I should yeah I don't even
know how to do that I know there there
are ways to put up graphics but I have
no idea how you do that in a live
YouTube video I'm gonna have to take
like a course or watch some videos on
how to livestream because I just I just
started doing this one day like
literally I had the idea one day and
then the very next day I just started
doing it so I didn't really take time to
to figure it out there's some are really
early videos you can tell I didn't take
time to figure it out because the
quality is terrible but all right so
what are you gonna have we're gonna have
a category right so the category is
gonna start out as all so I'll make sure
I have an all category potentially we
might at one at some point maybe think
about having a featured category so you
could show people actually that's a good
idea let me show you this one on now
right now I have this section that's
featured resources but maybe I could get
rid of it I'm not gonna make the
decision right now I don't think but
potentially I could get rid of this
section because I wasn't really sure how
I was gonna change this based on how I
change this UI anyway so I could just
save save the the thought about that it
could
simplify everything a lot make that
whole component a lot smaller in terms
of lines of code and JSX the default
category could be featured I'll think
about that for right now I'm gonna leave
it as all we don't have any categories
anyway right now so those all need to be
input and I don't I don't really think
it's the best use of my time to go in
and input those categories so I'm just
gonna have to let the people in charge
of the content know about the categories
I'll have to enable it in WordPress
because I disabled categories for that
post type I'll have to enable that and
then let them know and then hopefully
you know they'll add everything in and
we'll start to get some good good data
to be able to test out our category
drop-down so I think that's sort of
laughs now maybe we might want to switch
over how we do these I'd hate to do this
I mean we have this working already
should we switch these to basically do
the same use like the same system we
won't have to worry about the masonry
component and getting that to work
anymore it's gonna be different I'm just
gonna go and I'm gonna add a category
now or a I'm gonna add something into
the state object for it let's say type
so it's gonna be resource type and this
is also gonna be all by default and then
for search is there any reason to do the
search differently that we then we have
been yeah actually we will need to
this is there's really a good benefit to
doing this in that I have to say out
loud what I'm planning to do and in this
case I just caught what seems like a big
issue that I hadn't thought of before so
right now the search works by sending
requests to WordPress and getting an
entirely new set of data from WordPress
through the API every time something is
typed so that actually sent a request to
to WordPress and we got it back so it
works great it's really fast I mean yeah
I'd rather cut down on the the request
but this is how it works right now but
what I was describing a minute ago is I
wanted to use her to be able to filter
and then search but have all these
filters still applied so basically I
guess it I'm trying to think of a way
that I could avoid making another API
call and then simply just search the
data but I guess this doesn't change
anything will still search the search
will still show us data it will send
back data but then that data will be
passed through all these filters and
show up here so I don't see any way
around that the reason being I'm not I
don't think it's possible for me to grab
all of the data at first because there's
gonna there's going to be a lot of
resources at some point at least that's
the that's the vision of the people in
charge of this they're they're expecting
to have hundreds and hundreds of
resources the WordPress API limits you
to getting 100 posts at a time so I
can't in one API call get everything in
anyway so anyway having said all that if
you have any ideas let me know I'll
check the live chat now in case
someone's been in anyone's commented on
that I'm I'm not gonna attempt to tackle
this entire problem right now you know
we've already been streaming for an hour
so and this doesn't have the question
about the search thing does not have to
be answered yet to make this work so for
now I'm just gonna focus on this but I
just wanted to share my thought process
with you all to see if if anyone had any
ideas on that
Oh actually brandon has a good point in
the live chat I have a toggle right now
for free or paid but what if they want
both that's a great point and I yeah I
could definitely see ya a user might one
but they might not care whether or not
it's free or paid they just want to find
the resources they want and it would
actually be a pain for them to have to
click back and forth so maybe we
shouldn't maybe it shouldn't be a toggle
maybe it should be and maybe another
drop-down I hate to do another drug I
just don't like to have a ton of
dropdowns but that might be the only way
let me know if you think of a different
way the options would then be free paid
or all I guess or it could potentially
be checkboxes that say for your paid and
if none of them are checked and it's all
about a fault that might be a better
option if it's just two checkboxes for
free or paid and I guess it could be if
they're both checked then you get both
and if none of them are checked then you
still get both that might be a little
confusing but I don't
I don't see any other way to do it
because the resource is either gonna be
free or paid all right let me know what
you think
okay cool someone else said checkboxes
so weighty baifern fan 31 says
checkboxes so great okay rowan says he
leans drop-down with check box style
okay
tarek asked about throttling while
sending requests research actually I
didn't do it yeah I had sucked I assume
your I talked earlier when I set it up
about limiting the number of searches so
like a certain number of milliseconds
would have to pass before you're allowed
to send another API request I don't
think I actually I don't think I put
that in so no I haven't done it yet but
I intend to do that I think I put it in
my cello board if that if not I'm gonna
have to check and put it in there man 10
asks about caching there's some caching
going on right now I'm gonna also set up
some caching on the WordPress side
basically I just have to click a button
to enable it right now but it's already
set up
it's just through a plugin though asks
can you apply a filter to achieve all
posts regardless 100 limit oh cool it
looks like there's Stack Overflow I'm
gonna copy this now and check that out
as well I had read some stuff about
trying to get rid of the limit so I I
think I've read this one off I'll check
it out too but I think the answer was
like you'd have to build your own custom
like endpoint or something because
there's not like a default way to do it
so but I'll check it out
oh good okay bill also says how about
some sort of pagination with the posts
yeah a bucha says that's how these
single page applications like to work
get all the data then filter and sort
locally yeah I would love to be able to
filter sort of locally the problem for
me
is just right now I can get all the data
but in the future there there may be so
much data that that's not going to be a
good idea to get all the data Rowland
asks this WordPress what doesn't
WordPress do some caching by default
actually it might I'm not I'm not sure
if it caches by default the caching that
I am going to enable at some point once
I get all my post types settled is every
time an API call is made
instead of like normally it would go to
the database it's a sequel database and
then it would put together that data and
send it out instead what would happen is
that would be saved in the cache so you
make an API call and then it doesn't
have to hit the database again so I just
explained basic caching sorry sorry for
everyone who already knew that but let's
see yeah and Bill says I wouldn't rely
on it because the plugins creator will
fix in the future by sanitizing input
yeah okay Roland says displaying
hundreds of posts might be a bit
overwhelming it just puts a network
strain okay all right cool Brandon says
what if we just you know we only do an
API call on the search text box and then
filter those results that's what I was
thinking
yeah Bill recommends using Redux yeah
and I kind of wish that I had set it up
like that but you're right at this point
he also says that require rewrite of how
state is managed at this point yes at
this point I just don't have I don't
know if I gave you all the update maybe
I did I think I have until like the 19th
so I have to get as much as I possibly
can done on this site for
what's in my Trello board by the 19th
and then I have to move on to another
project so I'm actually learned I'm
taking the the Udacity react developer
course right now so I'm going to be
learning about how to use redux
I think it's Redux I can't remember
which one but one basically one of the
things that does what Redux does so I
know there's like Redux and mob X and so
one of those things I'm going to be
learning about but I'm not going to
learn about it and enough time to
implement it on this project so that's
unfortunate I think it would have been
better
okay Tariq says use of view more button
instead of pagination yeah that would be
good I was saying it maybe like view
more button here and then it just kind
of like I can either do a few more or I
could do infinite scroll what's your
opinion on this I could have it so that
once I get near the bottom of the page
it just automatically loads more which
may actually like it might require
another API called
on to be honest but we could see how I'd
do it or I could actually have a button
that users have to click oh cool Jacob
says that he's taking that course as
well awesome and they are teaching mob x
and redux good that's really cool I like
that they're gonna do do both of them
all right so enough thinking it's really
important to think these things through
to avoid wasted work and stuff but I
want to do something I actually want to
get a little bit of this working and
then that way if anybody really like
wanted to watch this because they were
interested in the topic and want to
learn how to do this I at least want to
do it I want to at least do a filter I
might not get to a sort today but I just
want to do one filter and get it working
obviously I'm there's gonna be some
changes made to it and you can all
follow along you know on github with the
changes and see the finished product at
some point